late bits this is the kill test
[Music]
the vajramusti wow
originating in india the vachamushti is
an edge knuckle duster the unique design
features sharpened blades on every side
of the handle making it a specialty
weapon only wielded by well-trained
indian warriors the sharp edges on all
sides provided the user with a wide
range of lethal attacks from deadly
stabs and slashes to devastating punches
a traditional indian martial art where
the weapon is tied to the fists of
wrestlers has lineage dating back to the
middle ages and is still practiced today
by professional wrestlers in india using
non-lethal knuckle dusters
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test to
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i will take your weapon
to deliver multiple lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy
kyle you're first you ready oh yeah
wow
all right kyle let's talk about your
weapon here i was worried about the
finger welds that you had there that
they would be an issue especially when
i'm punching no issues there i like the
fact that as it gets slippery it gave me
a very good grip overall it is a
beautiful piece and your weapon
will kill oh yeah
all right ben your turn sir are you
ready i'm ready let's do this
[Music]
all right ben let's talk about your
weapon here
the edges are very sharp
but there are some sharp edges that you
have in here every movement started to
give me a little bruise and cut off some
skin right there
but in terms of
what this weapon will do
it will kill thanks doug my hand
all right blade smith welcome to the
strength test
to test the strength and durability of
your vajra mushties as well as their
overall construction i'll be stabbing
and punching into this sheet metal and
chain kyle you're up first you ready for
this yep
all right kyle in this strength test
your two long blades held up great the
center blade here took some chipping on
that chain i'm looking at the grain in
there and it's it's pretty big i would
have liked to seen that refined but in
general these two blades held up well
nice job awesome thanks ben
all right ben you're up you ready for
this sure am
[Music]
all right ben well the first thing i
feel when i pick this weapon up is its
sheer mass i mean it's a heavy heavy
weapon that did you some justice in the
strength test the only thing i could see
is a little bit of glinting on the lower
blade but the middle blade
it took a pretty major deflection right
here
it kind of cracked one more little
little hit here and that would just come
off the main thing working against you
on this blade is
the rough inner surface
i couldn't really find a real
comfortable way of getting this finger
out of harm's way but after the strength
test is all in one piece
nice job thank you
all right bladesmiths we know your
weapons can heal and we know they are
strong now it's time to find out just
how sharp they are to find out i'll take
your weapons and deliver some stabs and
slices on these spice bags call you up
first you ready for this yup let's do
this
[Music]
all right let's talk about your weapon
it is comfortable it's a good fit on my
hand it's got a pointy enough tip over
there but with that one piece where
you're missing some edges it was more of
a jagged cut when it came to stabbing
and slashing on both weapons on each end
it'll cut good job thank you doug
bend your turns are you ready ready
let's go let's do it
right bench talk about your weapon
the weight that you have here back up
the cut because you have very sharp
edges and the cuts are very deep but my
hand when i'm making impact still rubs
on the inside of your handle but other
than that sir your beast
it will cut thanks doug
all right guys you guys both came
through with unbelievable pieces of work
unfortunately we can only send one of
you guys home with the title of fortune
fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars and our champion today
is
kyle congratulations ben unfortunately
you're not walking home to champion
today the time has come and have to ask
you to leave the fourth floor all right
thank you guys this was awesome for sure
kyle amazing job i busted my butt and
honestly did the best that i could so i
don't have any regrets
well kyle congratulations you'll be
leaving here with the title fortune fire
champion and a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations
thank you my wife's gonna be super
pumped when i tell her that i'm the next
fortune fire champion
what are you gonna do with that cash man
my wife and i are probably gonna use it
for a down payment on a house that's
absolutely fantastic
18 months ago i would have never
imagined being here today hell yeah i'm
forgetting fire champion
the tabar shish park
the tabar shishbar is an extremely rare
weapon that was used by mounted warriors
in india pakistan and afghanistan during
the 16th and 1700s the combination of
two deadly weapons the tabars axe was
sharp and lethal while the shish bar's
mace was just as dangerous using blunt
force to take down opponents
the mace could also contain up to eight
flanges that were able to penetrate
shields and bash through armor making
this brutal weapon a force to be
reckoned with
bladesmiths the tabar shishbar is one
weapon with multiple personalities
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i will take you to the
bar shish bart and use both ends to
deliver killing blows on this ballistic
stumming
mark you up first you ready
let's see it let's do this
[Music]
omar
it is sharp
that chopped right into the chest cavity
breaking a bone
this axe dug in and gutted him
your mace definitely will crush you can
see the breaking bones inside
your weapon will kill
thank you
chris you ready i am let's do this
oh my gosh
into the lung into the heart
your mace definitely penetrated through
the skull
bones
are broken i don't think it's gonna end
well
your weapon is heavy
and i'm not a fan of heavy weapons only
because you have to carry it to battle
but
overall
it will kill
thank you
all right gentlemen this is the
sharpness test
the two bar only has one sharp area
which is the axe head so i'll strike
into the side of beef six times with
each of your axes
mark you up first are you ready for this
mm-hmm okay
[Music]
your weapon's nice and light for a
weapon that looks as heavy as this is
you can see that this just went right
through
the ribs this is definitely a cutter
good job thank you chris
you ready
let's do it okay
well right off
the weight difference
i mean this thing hits like a ton
these hooks
tear meat coming out the back way
your edge there's no damage
that i can feel
it's heavy
but uh it does a hell of a lot of damage
nicely done thank you all right
gentlemen this is the strength test now
to test the strength and durability of
your tabar shish bars i'll be using all
parts of it to strike this suit of armor
mark you're up you ready yes i am let's
see it
[Music]
edge is still perfect
no chips no rolling
the hammer gave that armor a nice dent
didn't take any damage
mace is fine
the guy inside there was not happy
all right chris you ready for this don't
hold back
i'm not gonna
this is a heavy weapon yeah i mean i can
control it but
i don't have any rebound
and you've got just the smallest bit of
edge deformation here
other than that
mace is a devastator
you made a beautiful piece thank you i
hope the judges appreciate the
devastation my weapon's capable of
bringing
it's hard to say who's going to win
blade smith's the judge's deliberation
is complete and there can only be one
forged and fire champion and that
champion is
[Music]
mark congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion thank you
good job buddy thanks
chris
your blade did not make the cut please
surrender your weapon
mark congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion and will be receiving a
check for ten thousand dollars good job
how do you feel right now i feel great
chris a hell of an opponent
i'm glad it went to the very end i
wanted to see a real competition mark
please present your weapon to the judges
and shake our hands i won i am the
champion
unbelievable
i just won ten thousand dollars my wife
and i we made a deal she gets nine
thousand
and i get a thousand so congratulations
dear
a booge
named after the indian city of booze
this 18th century hybrid axe knife was
often used by the armies and bodyguards
of monarchs known as raja featuring a
broad single-edged blade mounted to a
long half the lethal weapon could be
wielded as a powerful two-handed battle
axe ideal for both hacking and slashing
warriors could also impose stealthy and
deadly attacks with the small stiletto
dagger concealed within the half the
pommel this brutal yet highly ornate
weapon was often inlaid with gold and
silver and features an elephant's head a
sacred animal
video game enthusiasts can virtually
wield the bouge as a raj put warrior in
the game deadliest warrior late smiths
welcome to the keel test
your boujas look beautiful but are they
deadly well to find that out i will take
your weapon and deliver killing blows on
two
pig carcasses
joey up first ready i'm ready
[Music]
novice
[Music]
[Music]
first up this blade
is sharp
the point is easy enough to get into the
carcass and snatching the way out
it's got a great feel to it
nice stiletto
there's even a handle that you put on
this so it gives a nice look to it
overall sir
this boosh
kill
thanks doug
all right benton
are you ready to hammer up ready to rock
and roll
[Music]
oh
man
sorry man
it's a big piece of shrapnel
damn it
well benton one of the things i like
about this you put on the leather it
gave me a very nice area to hold on to
and it's ovoid i can tell where the edge
is
but
the obvious happened
it's a coarse green structure here
i should have normalized that tang much
better than i did but when you're
grinding away long days in the shop
during this challenge and you're just
focused on the finish line it's easy to
overlook some things and obviously i did
well ben any warrior knows that if you
leave a piece of shrapnel that big in a
target it's deadly however a warrior
also knows that his weapon needs to be
strong and your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure in our very first
test
and therefore you cannot move forward in
this competition
come on brother
did a great job man
i feel pretty bummed but this challenge
has been both very difficult and
invigorating at the same time i've made
things that i've never made before
and i've overcome some challenges that
i've never had to face before so overall
it was a great experience
joe your blade is sharp deadly and
strong and you are the new forged and
fire champion and that's the title that
comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
how you feel right now it's a little
surreal i'm a forge to fire champion
i won but you know it'll be nice to win
after the three tests but this has been
a totally unique opportunity it's really
a big affirmation of my abilities
it's amazing
the conda
the conda is a sword that gained
popularity in medieval india during the
gupta period between 320 and 550 a.d the
word conde is derived from the sanskrit
word khan meaning to break divide cut or
destroy
its wide fake straight blade was not
only used for thrusting but also as a
hacking weapon
a rajput warrior was surrounded by the
enemy he would pull out the conda and
fight to the end while swinging the
blade with both hands taking down as
many enemies as he could in an honorable
last stand
bladesmiths this is a kill test to test
the lethality and function of your
weapon i will take your weapon and
deliver three vertical chops and then a
slice
then you're up you ready
guess so
[Music]
well ben the damage that your blade did
cut about
six inches deep into both shoulders and
right through the spine
on the horizontal slice pretty much cut
all the way through
it's got a good feel
[Music]
this sir
will kill thank you
tom it's your turn you ready i'm ready
[Music]
tom you definitely cut in about six
inches deep on the shoulders and about
eight inches into the spinal column
cut halfway through into the carcass
also feels good in balance with a
downward vertical slice
there was a slight bend that's happening
to your blade
but
it will kill
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
i will slash across these bungee cords
if your blade is sharp it should cut all
the way through if not it may just push
it aside or bounce off
ben you're up are you ready
sure
well ben your sword started to cut cut a
little bit but it did not cut through
it feels good on the slice
the handle is very comfortable in the
hand
once again it didn't cut through so it
brings into question the sharpness
tom it's your turn you ready i'm ready
let's do this
well tom
it did cut a little bit into the bungee
cord but then as you can see the
transference of energy went all the way
back to the blade it wasn't sharp enough
to cut through
and it bent
your blade
which brings to question the heat
treatment you did on your blade
cut around corners now it will cut
around quarters this time right but in
this particular case
it will not cut sir
gentlemen both of your weapons failed in
the sharpness test
historically in battle blades bent
tom
we'd like to give you the opportunity to
straighten your blade so that you can
continue with this fight
however we will be taking that bend into
consideration when it comes to final
judging i understand
should have left it thicker but i'm not
a quitter
i'm gonna fight to the end
okay tom you've straightened your blade
we can continue with testing
dave
gentlemen
this is the strength test i'm gonna take
five chops into these copper pipes
and see how far through we can split
ben are you ready
not at all
yes
[Music]
well
ben it's still one piece but barely
and the the dimensions of your guard
here on my hand are perfect
your blade is held up beautifully nicely
done thank you
so tom your turn okay all right
so tom what happened is we lost a piece
of the guard right there yeah with the
broken guard and the bend earlier i feel
it's unsafe to continue
all right thank you tom
i'm disappointed i know i could do
better but
that's what happens when you don't use
your time right
gentlemen in just five days you've both
done an amazing amount of work on your
condos
but in this arena there can only be one
forged and fire champion
[Music]
ben
you are the forest empire champion
tom unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut please surrender your
weapon
well i got to meet some real nice
craftsmen
and i learned don't let your age slow
you down
you don't know how long you got
ben congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion and will be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars good
job
most people get guard sizes all wrong
and the conda has a deceptively small
guard you just hit it out of the park
thank you it feels amazing to be a
fortune fire champion it's a wonderful
validation of a long time of night
making and i made new friends i
made 10 grand i mean what more could you
ask for
[Music]
the indian two-handed sword
emerging around the 17th century this
rare two-handed sword joins some of the
most iconic bladed weapons produced in
the indian subcontinent the long
double-edged blade reached lengths of up
to five feet and was so heavy it
required the wielder to use two hands
for more accurate strikes
it also featured three brass globes
positioned on the shaft that offered a
more secure grip as well as a
counterbalance for the heavy blade
despite its substantial size the blade
was designed to flex by the mid 18th
century improved gunpowder technology
spread throughout india making the
indian two-handed sword obsolete
bladesmiths this is the kill test to see
what kind of lethal damage your weapon
will do we'll take your sword and
deliver killing blows on this boar
carcass jonathan you're up first you
ready go for it
[Music]
all right jonathan let's talk about your
sword right here
first up it's sharp
definitely lacerate it through easily
when wielding this weapon there's a nice
balance to it overall your weapon sir
will kill
thank you ed
are you ready i am
[Music]
all right ed let's talk about your
weapon right here first up i like the
leather wrapping that you did right here
on the handle it gives it a good grip
your blade is a little bit on the
heavier side
but upon the swing it lacerates deeply
into the carcass
it will kill
gentlemen this is the dreaded bone chop
remember this test is all about what the
bones do to your blades and not what
your blades do to the bones
ed you're up first are you ready
[Music]
[Music]
well jonathan it's a similar result
there is some edge chipping here as well
the handle being round on one of the
hits did roll in my hand
aside from
edge chipping
held up very well well done thank you
[Music]
all right gentlemen to test the
sharpness of your blade i'll be cutting
through these pumpkins we'll take a look
at those cuts see how clean they are
jonathan you're up are you ready ready
[Music]
[Music]
nice
so jonathan you can see your blade
has such a flexibility to it and when it
hit
the blade actually warped out cut over
and through
the heck of a cutter nicely done thank
you
all right ed you're up are you ready
[Music]
all right ed
that's a good clean cut on that pumpkin
you kind of see what happened i started
compensating for the weight
and pulled up and through the weight
factor
in me using it is an issue but
definitely sharp definitely a good
cutter well done
it's really hard to say one way or the
other right now who could and couldn't
win this thing
jonathan ed the judges have finished
their deliberation and there can only be
one forced empire champion and that
champion is
jonathan congratulations you are a new
fortune fire champion ed
your sword didn't make the cut please
surrender your blade
i agree with the judge's decision his
blade was more usable i made a good
blade he made a little bit better play
no matter what i'm still a happy cat
jonathan good job
you
are a new forge of fire champion and
that's the title that comes with a check
for how much money ten thousand dollars
ten thousand dollars that's right thank
you jonathan please present your blade
to the judges on one voice to fire
that's pretty awesome it's not really
sunk in yet that i won i'd love to have
one of those grinders so
i might buy some shop tools too just
we'll see
[Music]
the cora
the cora sword originated in nepal where
it was wielded for centuries by a
legendary group of soldiers the gurkhas
the gurkhas were known for their
fearless military prowess and
weapons-based martial arts which
included symbolic weaponry like the cora
sword
this fearsome sword features a long
curved blade that flares outward at the
tip maximizing the force of each swing
and making it an ideal weapon for both
slashing and chopping
also used in sacrifice a skilled cora
wielder could reportedly cut a sheep in
half with just one swing
the nepalese cora was a blade that had a
distinct inward curve the spatulated
flare at the tip making it a weapon for
slicing and chopping now we'll cut
across these sandbags let's see how
sharp your blades are
josh you're up first you ready i'm ready
let's do it
josh great balance
the blade really wants to chop and slice
the recovery on the blade makes it one
that wants to continue for combat one
problem i have here is this handle it
tends to roll but other than that
it will cut good job sir thank you
liam you're up next are you ready
when he said that this was heavy
you weren't kidding this is a chopper
a little hard to control on the recoil
but not enough to where i can't wield it
this sir
will cut
great good job
next up is a strength test
dave
gentlemen to test the strength of your
cora i'm gonna take one blow into these
skulls josh you're up you ready i'm
ready all right fantastic
nice
josh
went right into the skull swings easy
super lightweight
but uh
like doug said the handle wants to roll
in my hand
nonetheless
nicely done thank you
all right moving on you ready yeah okay
wow
that's a beast
it feels really nice in the hand you did
a great job on this handle obviously we
pretty much took care of that skull
now this thing once you get it started
it's going to go right
my only worry is is stopping it yeah you
don't always have to have a heavy blade
to make a heavy blow
but it's a beautiful piece it's a nice
job thank you well done
liam josh both of your weapons are
spectacular but in this competition
there can only be one champion
and that champion is
liam congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion josh unfortunately
your blade did not make the cut please
surrender your weapon
i came here to challenge myself and i
came here to hopefully represent
bladesmithing well and i think i did
that liam congratulations you were the
forest and fire champion and will be
receiving a check for 10 grand good job
you are our youngest champion so far
congratulations great job good job
[Applause]
i just won fours and fire just wow
this is a big feat for me to accomplish
against master smith i think that all
the people that i went to high school
with they'll finally realize it's not
just a hobby it's something that i can
really succeed at i'm gonna use the ten
thousand dollars and just put it
straight into a new shop and uh these
are like my only pair of jeans
so maybe i'll get another pair of jeans
the hilari
the hilati was a fearsome double-bladed
dagger created in ancient india the two
recurved blades would needed a straight
handle and could be used for slashing or
stabbing some hilaries even featured a
third blade running out of the handguard
though the hilati might seem like
something out of a fantasy video game it
actually dates back to the mid 5th
century and was wielded by the rajput a
major hindu clan known for their bravery
and ferocity in battle
late smiths the haladi was a weapon used
by the rashford warriors it was designed
to have a blade on both sides of the
handle and they were known to be very
sharp
to see how sharp your weapons are i will
take your blade and deliver multiple
cuts and stabs to this canvas bag ray
you're up first you ready i'm ready
let's do this
okay ray
i like the design of your blade it feels
good in the hand you got that ovoid
shape for the handle and i like also how
it flares over there so it stops for the
thrust
i love your recurve and damascus pattern
that you have on both ends of your blade
it's very dramatic and it looks good
the belly
of your blade
slashed nicely on the canvas and it
allowed for a good thrust
and this blade
will cut
good job thank you
steven you're up next you ready hell
yeah let's do this
going up against a master bladesmith
with 30 years experience is definitely a
little nerve-wracking for me but i'm
pretty sure i got everything executed
perfectly on it well steven
we have a big problem
here what's the problem
we specifically asked for a recurve on
each blade
these blades
are not recurve
they're simply curved
we put that specifically on our
parameters so that both blades are equal
and fair in all the tests that we do
your blade does not have that s-shape
recurve that we're looking for
because you don't have that s-shaped
recurve that we needed for the
parameters we cannot move on to test
your blade
well steven
the devil's in the details
the blade parameters were very specific
we asked for counter recurve blades on
your helati you didn't deliver that
therefore since your weapon cannot be
tested fairly and evenly
i must ask you to please leave the forge
i'm feeling a little bummed i put in all
that hard work and didn't even get to
test it i still feel really proud of my
work it's just i failed to see the one
small detail and that
led me to losing
i learned i gotta follow the
instructions a little better
ray congratulations you are the forge
and fire champion and will be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars good
job
thank you
it's a good-looking weapon sir
thank you i love your damascus pattern
really really nice recurve with
beautiful shape how do you feel right
now feeling really good being a
forgerfire champion it's it's really
nice especially at my age
i felt a lot better about it if it you
know if they could have did the cutting
contest and everything with his blade
also but i just sold a knife for 10 000
bucks
that's the best part
[Music]
you